[Music]
life lessons news Oh tell me to detail
submitted by Armani thinks David is cute
no no I don I liar come on hahaha
here are seven mistakes we make in our
twenties that are actually good for us
in our 30 oh [ __ ] it's a [ __ ]
listicle guys you haven't done one of
these in a minute I know I hope people
like it because they [ __ ] hate
listicles let's do it
number one dating a string of players
I never dead not dated of string players
this for the ladies well when all is
said and done you kind of have to think
the players were playing they make you
appreciate all the loyal honest good
people when like he or she finally comes
into your life or you have a better
ditch so the stereotype is true you know
when they're young they [ __ ] it out
and then when they retire and nobody
wants them anymore they get with a nice
guy I don't really need to make that
mistake myself I could see other people
make the mistake pretty good and I
learned from it yes so I don't really
need anything most people want to start
off just appreciating good people but
then there's no good people out there
because they're selfish number two
having a shitty job that this I agree
with yeah babby starting off at a job
where you're basically someone else's
[ __ ] may seem like a mistake in your
20s but it will make you work harder and
challenge yourself you'll thrive in
another job someday because you won't
ever be taken surrounded I had like five
shitty jobs I had a horrible slice job I
had a shitty job since I was 2 years old
all the way to lolly about 25 do you
work anywhere else besides the hair what
did the Men's Warehouse I was a youth
pastor
I also Oh Macy's who are your five
counts hi oh I was a telemarketer and
then I sold mortgages huh oh that is Mya
I worked at Big Five for one day oh I
taught students I was a tutor in the
military and what else selling sex toys
I sold sex toys are you based on that
cheaters that is she and all the really
should take textbooks yeah big tick yeah
yeah yeah the International editions
they're just okay they just don't pay
the copyright dues so they're way
cheaper all the same book it's that same
book number three dropping your life
savings on experiences so for this one
in particular they're talking about when
you're in your 20s you're so pro because
like you you just want to travel the
world you just want to see everything
and you just want to just go into a
different place right experience the
culture how's the food right and so when
you're in your 30s you now know exactly
what pieces you want to go back to
that's one load of [ __ ] [ __ ] because
I was broke as hell and I saw all my
friends travel in their 20s and I was
like man [ __ ] you [ __ ] just kidding
I'll just tell it alright good for you
guys you know but I couldn't join them
but now I can join them but you have to
well I actually did more like so for
example when I was I would go to Vegas
and then maybe some of us would you know
stay at a cheap-ass motel and I would
look at the Bellagio and be like man one
day I want to stay there and guess what
for a JK trip we got the penthouse yeah
I remember I had my life savings
actually came from financial aid and
then with that money instead of spending
it on school because they I just got way
more than I needed I just bought a car
I'm like yeah free dog I guess it
depends on the person
yeah because you know most people I
think they could spare using their life
savings and a little thing like you
spending money to experience life is
considered a mistake I don't think
that's a mistake at all I think that's
what you should do areas made for ya
that's what you're supposed to I think
it's just a mistake when you don't have
parents paying for you and you put it
for for me like it's like I have to pay
rent I'd if you drop it irresponsible
yeah I can't I can't use that money on
vacations because I need to do thing
like life savings like it's your savings
like it's not your actual money that you
need to survive all because I didn't
have any savings number four sleeping
until the afternoon
on weekends you may miss out on brunch
plans and getting a jumpstart on your
screen cleaning near 20s but you really
begin to see in your 30s how Beautyrest
is a real thing yeah I was never able to
do that really what is my body just my
just barges way stuff at like 10:00 or
11:00 no matter what I always see people
do that I'm so envious I'm like Tammy
woke up at 3:00 I bet that feels good I
could unlike you well not as intense as
you but I'm like you where I can't my
body just won't allow after certain
hours so I think you live in might have
been deleted but then just getting up
like stretching and go back to sleep
correct yeah people I miss that anyone
that cleans I hear people getting up and
they're like making the oatmeal then
they go back to sleep and they can sleep
for my 10 and back all the other three
no I thought about that that's
impossible to me that's [ __ ] possible
number one that sleep is terrible it
feeling [ __ ] watching a movie in change
possibly just knock out and then you
wake that every like I just you know all
I really want and it's something that I
very get rarely it's like when I sleep
and then I wake up and I feel refreshed
I don't think I've had that in like like
like seven or eight months like there
yeah
Hawaii yeah that's that's where oh
that's where happens the vacations right
not the [ __ ] out mm-hmm I hear you're
not the sauce ha ha ha that's where I
get the whole aisle I'm come here number
five going for the nice car and pushing
yourself further into debt but I'm the
girl older it's a nice car for you to
drive I can account on camera so they're
saying when you're 20 should buy a nice
car
no that's a mistake it's a mistake but
then as you grow older you find that it
is a nice car to drive when you're in
your thirties what this [ __ ] dump
yeah I can just get the shitty car when
you got money you buy a nice car later I
know that's what they're called that's
why it's a mistake that you do in your
20 that you don't do know but they're
saying that you the the car that you
have announced an appreciating value in
the next 10 years
they're saying it's a mistake that you
do to 20s that pays off in the third
okay off yeah oh how is it how is the
car binder 20s 10 years later going to
be better than the cars which is like a
classic that only one was ever made like
get the [ __ ] out here with that [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] like I said still fast
Toyota Camry 10 years later here's a
piece you about a 1995 Lexus and right
is the [ __ ] that's that's example that
[ __ ] domain
I wanted that Sun pick up number six
burying yourself in work to build up
your career that's pretty good action
it's a great thing
mmm especially their twenties or they
should kill yourself yeah cause like in
this example they're just saying that in
your 20s you tend to work a lot and
because you work a lot you don't spend
enough time with your family and friends
and so by the time you're 30 like it's a
relationship that you would appreciate I
don't know I was late yes
but in my 20s and I loved it I think
it's one of the greatest things yeah or
you know what I did work a lot but I
also enjoy I think I enjoyed life I'm
not sure at all but then also on this
point they also say like by working hard
in your 20s you do climb up the ladder
to become a boss in your career by the
time you're 30 so you'll be [ __ ]
wouldn't want both or experience what do
you want and for the last one number
seven take the path you think you should
take instead of identifying the right
one for you I agree
a thousand percent because I always knew
my heart was telling me do something but
my fears and brains told me to miss
risky but I'm so [ __ ] happy I was a
stubborn sack of [ __ ] and I believe in
my heart I'm a hot yeah you gotta follow
your heart you don't follow your heart
very times it's always not going to feel
right and you're always going to try to
trick yourself to do something when it
doesn't need to be that way
don't let the fear win it's so
satisfying when you overcome it and be
like oh my god it's like I'm liberated
also know yourself too because I've met
some people who wanted to follow the
heart and a talent that they did very
hard life they should come to terms with
it very early on like if let's say
someone [ __ ] sucks at singing and
they're 20 they probably can develop the
skill in ten years if they work
diligently and they take it like serious
if their tone dust and know so if
they're toned up is just you can't hear
music it's just not possible for you how
do you like in
your boys Oh Oh technology oh yeah
there's a lot of the component there's
like youtubers right now that without
YouTube without auto-tune they sounds
absolutely terrible
that's like texture to their voice you
know they fill it in with a lot of
reverb and [ __ ] so you know when you go
to share these people live it's kind of
like you don't sound as good what
happened
mmm it's not a bad thing it's just
that's how music is now but that's what
they call recording artists yeah you
know how to utilize the vocal booth very
very very well exactly do you had a
dream because you should follow it my
dream is to have a womb there's a couple
things I wish I would have followed my
heart earlier one was in the military I
didn't really like take advantage of all
the opportunities I was given to me
because my brain was set on like medical
school and what kind of opportunities so
one of them was my unit was really
special and I could have went to jump
school and then so if you go to jump
school to consider airborne and like
because of how hard Marine Corps boot
camp is like the same thing as be an
Army Ranger
you jump out of a plane so like you
become you become I jump certify and
that's something that I really wanted to
do but because it's three weeks long
randomly like in the middle of my
quarters that means I would have to take
that entire quarter off do it looking
back now I should just done it mmm but I
was so focused on getting through
Medical School I don't want to delay
that another thing was I really wanted
to do a GoPro and anime or boy toy
like just not not like become like crazy
series but just be able to get my pro
car and I was like and whenever I got
too serious and it pulled me away from
something else I was I just an option
for me which away from school I'll tell
you there's no injures although one pro
kickboxing won his first match who in
yourself what yeah for at the age of 42
[ __ ] don't
42 never too late he went pro and then
he won his first match when did he start
training at 30 like 30 or some [ __ ] like
41 year old for a year but he he was an
amateur kickboxer when he was younger
see that's different well that yes
foundation yeah that's but either way
like what you see him in the beginning -
he was pretty bad you know I mean I mean
why'd you like like 15 years of not
kickboxing at all whatsoever you're
pretty much starting fresh yeah yeah I'm
not I mean that's like saying would me
and my tech mando when I was like [ __ ]
twelve years old is going to work now
yeah you know I mean so I think for you
it's still a possibility but at least
for you to get your pro card right now
I'm scared gave her you work out like
you hurt your you beat yourself up for
no reason all the time we can you brush
your teeth let me tell you wash your
face when you wash your face it looks
like you're trying to get acid off of it
gets on fire now exactly
you better not be missing though just
kidding news uploads so go down and
subscribe for our channel so you can see
more video okay and there's another one
up here check it out
[Music]